Lasers are everywhere. In doctors' surgeries,
your DVD player, even in the club.
But before lasers came MASERs - like lasers
but using microwaves instead of light.
Based on an effect predicted by Einstein,
MASERs were invented in the 1950s.
But scientists only ever
managed to make them
either at super-cold temperatures
or a high vacuum.
They did find some uses, like amplifying
faint signals from deep space.
But they were soon eclipsed
by the much more practical laser.
Well now scientists have found a new way
to generate MASERs
at room temperature.
And they did it with
diamonds.
I went to the London Centre for
Nanotechnology to find out more.
I'm Jonathan Breeze,
I'm a research fellow at
Imperial College London.
and I've been working on room-temperature
MASERs for the past eight years.
And recently we managed to demonstrate
a continuous room temperature MASER
that uses Diamond.
Before getting to that though, Jon took
me through how MASERs and lasers work.
the MASER acronym and
the laser acronym both stand for
either Microwave or Light, Amplification
by Stimulated Emission of Radiation.
In order to get stimulated emission
what you need is a population
of electrons where you have two energy
levels, and there are more electrons in a
higher energy level than
a lower energy level.
This 'putting electrons into a higher state'
is called a population inversion.
If you can make one of those
then the MASER fun can begin.
An incoming photon causes one of the electrons
to drop down to a lower energy level.
When it does that it emits a photon,
and not just any photon, one that's identical
to the photon that just zoomed by.
These then trigger more electrons
to drop releasing more photons
in a chain reaction that scientists call
stimulated emission.
It's a sort of  exponential
photocopier for photons.
and if the photons are in the microwave part
of the spectrum, boom - you get a MASER.
So it was possible to make the population inversion
in rubies, which they used for MASERs.
But the population didn't last very long so it
only lasted for a fraction of a billionth of a second.
And so they had to cool it
down to cryogenic temperatures
to make it last for a few
millionths of a second.
So it was still quite short amount of time.
Jon and his colleagues
needed to find a material
that could sustain
a population inversion
at room temperatures.
They had some success with an organic polymer
but that could only generate
a pulsed MASER.
To make a continuous version
they turned to diamonds.
So you can see actually, this is the core of the MASER.
And then inside you can
see the diamond NV centre,
NV centre diamond. There are many
colour centers in diamonds and
NV center is one of the most extensively
researched colour centre in the diamond.
NV centers, or nitrogen vacancies, are
defects in the diamond structure
which also make it pink.
Where carbon atoms are knocked out,
electrons sit in the gaps.
The electrons can exist at levels that
are separated by the right amount of
energy to emit microwaves.
And the diamond's
stable structure keeps a
population inversion
even at room temperature.
As well as the diamond
there's a sapphire resonator
which acts like a mirror to help intensify
the microwaves the MASER produces.
And everything is kept
in a copper housing called a cavity.
So basically this MASER
assembly comprising the cavity
the sapphire ring resonator
and the MASER medium - this diamond
will go in between the poles of the magnet,
a powerful magnet.
And then what we do, actually
we shine a green laser.
And when the laser hits  the NV centres,
the diamond glows a rich pink.
that's actually just a by-product
of a much more important process
putting the electrons into their
higher energy state.
When this is combined with a
precisely calibrated magnetic field
you get that crucial population inversion.
Then add the sapphire resonator
and the copper housing,
and out pops a MASER.
When we first got involved with the diamond
I did quite a bit theory.
I'm generally theory led,
so I don't want to waste my time doing an
experiment that I know won't work.
And all the theory pointed
towards it working.
We had been trying for about a year to kind of
observe this amazing phenomenon
and we'd had no kind of
positive results.
And then we saw this
quirky phenomenon
and I knew what that was and I got very excited.
So the next day everyone was there,
We all excited actually
so it was a really great day.
You guessed it,
they'd made a MASER.
I had to go for a walk
to calm myself down.
So yeah, it wasn't a 'Eureka moment' but it
was definitely, you know, a 'we did it moment.'
Their MASER is still pretty weak,
but it's a proof of principle.
And the fact that it uses
NV center diamonds is exciting,
because these are already being
studied for other applications.
Quantum computing, at room temperature,
and also what's called quantum metrology.
The fact that we we use that kind of
diamond for our MASER,
should hopefully open up a new branch in this
kind of quantum diamond technology.
This technique could not only make for
cheaper and more convenient MASERs,
it might mean MASERs end up being
used in loads more places than today.
But since this device is new it's hard
to know yet where that will be.
Over the past half century or so
lasers have cropped up everywhere.
Now the MASER's found a new lease of life
who knows where it could end up.